thanks for having me it was a
fascinating panel just before this so it
was a fantastic prelude to this
conversation in particular and what I'm
gonna try to do for you today is explain
to you how we're thinking about
cognitive computing at IBM Watson some
of the things we're doing to apply it in
the real world how we're opening it up
to innovators and entrepreneurs which is
part of the reason you know we've got a
big presence here in the UK and
throughout the rest of the world so my
goal today is just to show you a little
bit of really practical application of
the technology the ecosystem that we're
building and ultimately give you a few
examples of what we're doing so I wanted
to start here because I think it's a
interesting precursor to to where IBM
ultimately kind of got to this this
place I'm actually it's a bit of a
daunting task because we've been
studying machine learning and artificial
intelligence for about three decades we
spend roughly six billion dollars a year
on research and development at IBM and a
big portion of this over the last
probably 12 to 15 years has been focused
on cognitive technology so I'm
representing those 20,000 researchers
that spend every waking moment thinking
about this I'm simply a voice of it
which I'm you know proud to be that but
it's a lot of really fascinating work
that's gone on and so we have a hundred
year history when I think we're 104
years old now as a company and Thomas
Watson the namesake of the Watson
technology said this early on you know
that our machine should be nothing more
than tools for extending the powers of
human beings and that's how we think
about Watson side by side you know
working in tandem with with those of us
that are skilled professionals and
knowledge workers that's how you see it
put to work with oncologists at some of
the big cancer research firms with some
of the bankers and how they have to deal
with volumes of information that's
moving at the speed of light so let me
just take one second and explain when we
say cognitive computing what we mean I
mentioned briefly it's it's this kind of
sweet spot combination of artificial
intelligence natural language processing
and machine learning all brought
together we deal with what we call
unstructured information so 80% of the
world's data right now is on
shirred that's these are the emails that
tweets the blogs the journals the you
know newspaper articles that we're all
drowning in and to date we have not been
able to get to all of the insights and
knowledge that comes out of this this
sort of freeform text if you will so
when we look at this field of study and
how we're bringing it to market it's how
do we get to those domains of expertise
with the professionals that serve those
particular industries and try to pull
out the expertise such that Watson
becomes a colleague to those experts I
wanted to show you this I found it
fascinating we had a big event in
Brooklyn New York a few weeks ago and it
was called the world of Watson and it
was just our way to kind of bring alive
a lot of the you know the new areas of
study and some of the the demonstrations
of technology and this was a mural that
was painted real time at the event over
the course of two days he's a famous
artist on New York called Steven holding
but what's interesting is he was
actually working with Watson as his
colleague while he while he painted this
what they did was it's called a color
app and so it applied artificial
intelligence to all of the images that
are associated in this case with Watson
it looked through hundreds of thousands
of images and it looked at the emotion
that those images invoke on particular
segments or sub segments of the
population
so what kind of inspiration could the
color lead to when you're trying to kind
of draw a specific emotion out of that
crowd and in this case we were you know
trying to bring out innovation and
growth based on the population of of
executives and business leaders that
were there so over the course of the two
days he he was guided by Watson head and
Watson's hand terms of the colors that
he used to paint this mural I think you
know just to bring it back to the real
world many of you are publishers or have
magazines you know you can see how this
might be applied as you release you know
your new summer collection and you want
a feeling of warmth and openness and
discovery you could easily use these
kind of technologies to go find out how
your population is today responding you
know to certain colors
certainly images so apologies for the
grainy video but I wanted to show this
so this gentleman is one of our leading
roboticists inside of the IBM Watson
research labs he actually studied under
a gentleman named rod Brooks who's a
leading robot assist out of MIT and I'm
going to show you a short video you're
going to be introduced to a robot called
Eli and how we're starting to work you
know man and machine side by side
he like grabbed it
he like rabbit I'm confused
make sure the boy things do you mean you
I what color is the object on the left
each blue Eli grab it
Eli grab that object
Eli grab the white thing do you need
these ones no the other one he like grab
the green thing
sorry that's too big for me
he liked what is the object on the left
I don't know he liked that object is
aspirin okay
he liked this object is advil he liked
how many advil do you see I see to you I
poke the thing in the middle I don't
know something
Eli point out it you know I extend your
hand
you know I retract your hand you I that
is how you cook something okay something
you know I poke the red object so there
you go
this is um you know I know we had an
earlier discussion about kind of you
know what could potentially happen with
these technologies but there are
real-world applications we did a an
interesting joint venture with Softbank
out of Japan recently and they have a
robot called pepper and so they're
putting pepper to work in the banks in
the schools and the hospitals they have
a real shortage of folks that can work
in some of these locations and so pepper
will have Watson inside and essentially
be able to interact with customers and
patients and students accordingly so
you'll start to see some some real-world
application I wanted to talk about this
and it and it may seem frivolous but
it's an example that's important for all
of us
we actually taught Watson the chemistry
and science behind cooking so while you
know most of us may just enjoy the dish
the look of the dish the style of
cuisine there's actually a deep
chemistry behind it which is how
combinations of food tastes good
together and why there's a science
underlying called the hedonic
psychophysics so what gives us pleasure
at the molecular level we taught Watson
all of these things and then we fed it
about 9,000 recipes so we worked with
it's called the Institute for Culinary
Education out of New York City and bone
Appetit magazine and we taught Watson as
much as we could about
the most common ways that a chef would
combine certain ingredients for
traditional dishes but then importantly
we used kind of an additional set of
algorithms to say teach it surprise
pleasantness and synergy so Watson
surprised us with some dishes that we
wouldn't normally put together ourselves
it was quite interesting and Hannah my
apologies because I'm not able to bring
this up live I'm going to show you just
two quick screenshots but I wouldn't ask
you if you have time to go see our folks
are demoing this in the foyer and you
can play with it yourself if you know
you have interesting things in your
refrigerator that you're sort of bored
with that you might want to go try to
you know spice it up at home then this
is a way to do that what you'll see when
you get into the boma bone Appetit
application though is the first question
so I pre-populated this it says you know
what do you want to cook with what's
your what's your main ingredient and in
this case I put sausage and then the
question there enough ain't an
underneath that is what do you want to
exclude from the dish so I excluded
celery seeds since I don't like the
taste of this what it does then is it
comes up with a whole set in this case
it frittata bites with charred sausage
and feta a whole set of ingredients and
recipes it uses what we call discovery
technology to go out and find these
interesting combinations and ultimately
present you with some options all the
way from you know keep it classic right
if you don't want to kind of get too
dangerous with your cooking all the way
to surprise me and just you know toss it
up and see what happens
so it's interesting we actually
published a cookbook and it was sold out
on Amazon after a few days and as I
talked to people that are buying it
they're are having really interesting
dinner parties with this so take that as
you will just one one moment on what we
mean by ecosystem and I heard Julie
Mayer speak to this earlier that
ecosystems are becoming quite prevalent
and that's true for us as well we we had
an opportunity to offer up this
technology to entrepreneurs and said you
tell us what do you want to do with it
right come to us what we will do is give
you the technology for free we'll give
you the resources will help you during
the build cycle and tell us what you'd
like to do and it
it's been a wild ride my colleague nish
is here with me it's been 15 months of
just non-stop
discussions with veterinarians with you
know folks that are trying to optimize
supply chains space exploration I'm
gonna show you a toy a really cool
dinosaur that was created to using the
technology so what's fun for us on a
day-to-day basis is we have offered this
up to anyone and anybody in any company
that wants to take advantage of it based
on the industry that you're serving so
we found a lot of really great things I
am gonna show you this it's a real short
video it's a company called elemental
path and they're out of Silicon Alley in
New York City and this company could
actually not exist have it not been for
Watson so it's interesting story as kind
of the the backdrop here
the gentleman who founded it his his
wife is actually a teacher of autistic
children and if any of you either have
children with autism or know of children
they tend to interact with technology
much more so than people and so they
were talking about a way in which
children could start to engage with
technology in a more meaningful way and
they created what they called cognate to
which is this dinosaur it learns and
adapts based on the interactions with
your children so what you know
specifically one of the questions your
child is asking what do they like what
do they dislike
and it's teaching and interacting with
them accordingly
hi my name is Lily what is this bead of
light one two three four five six tell
me a knock-knock joke
who's there this letter so my favorite
color is orange you later alligator
tell me a story so it's just a fun
example I think you know we talked about
really interesting ways that technology
is being put to good use transforming
industries you know solving some of the
the biggest most pervasive problems in
the world like cancer but it's also
being put to work in in fun ways as well
there's another good example something
that I had never thought of until this
company came forward out of Canada
called life learned so if you think
about the life of a veterinarian it's no
different and in fact sometimes more
complicated than our physicians there
are so many different types of species
that are coming into your you know your
office they're flying in they're
crawling in their slithering in and they
can't talk to you they can't tell you
what's wrong with them so what they've
done is they've actually sort of
harnessed all of the the medical
journals veterinary journal is
associated with veterinary medicine as
well as sort of taught the system based
on some of the you've got about 5,000
veterinarians that they work with today
who are teaching Watson when it gets it
right and when it gets it again it gets
it wrong and this technology will be
then available you know at the
fingertips of these veterinarians as
they do their work day to day so against
it
a very different way to look at using
this so that's the future we see that
this is you know here with us today I
did briefly want to mention to you we
launched about three months ago just
based on as much energy as there was
around the medical community when we
first launched Watson we launched
Watson's health about two months ago so
what that what we've done with that is
started to look at all of the data the
patient data treatment data drug
interactions outcome data medical images
and we're bringing all of that together
we partnered with Apple and so we
partner with their health kit technology
Johnson & Johnson they've created a
diabetes advisor based on all of this
information
Medtronic so if you have a hip or a knee
replacement you need to get back to you
know normal life quickly enough what are
some of the ways that you can leverage
some of the information that that's you
know been most helpful for most patients
so you know we think this has a
tremendous runway in front of us we know
there'll be more more opportunities for
other innovators to start to build on
top of this as well which is really
where I want to leave you you know today
I think that the you know the the
century now is for us to be able to
leverage the technology we have
fortunately been able to offer this up
to entrepreneurs or or businesses
anybody that wants to make use of it so
please if you'd like to talk further
about a business that you have or are
thinking about we're happy to help and I
appreciate really spending some time
with us today Thanks
you